hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse and I'm Jesse and my beard
decided not to stream with us today oh I
have a face I forgot what it looked like
anyway today we're gonna do something
that is very new to me and that's unit
testing so if you've seen a lot of the
streams then you'll probably remember me
admitting this several times and being
called out for it that we do have
testing setup
I just don't write the testing oh no
noble noble and Savage is gone now they
were only here for the beard I guess
oh whoa my co-workers thought I should
just shave half a beard that would have
been the best of both worlds I guess
maybe I'll try it let's try it next time
it shouldn't take me too long to grow a
beard again that's probably a month and
I can get it nice and bushy again but my
wife's really happy about it so she'll
be happy I just hope my kids recognize
me sometimes the little ones like they
freaked out a bit if I shave my beard so
we'll see you later on when I go home
see I was gonna say something was I
gonna say oh I have a lot of updates so
I've been working on the site so I
didn't stream the last two days I work
from home the last two days and to be
entirely honest with you I was feeling
pretty depressed I haven't worked out in
a while
and I I just was feeling depressed and
when it like that it's really hard
anybody has depression you know it's
really hard to interact with people and
do things so I would just think like
okay what am I gonna do what am I gonna
stream about today and I just couldn't
think of a topic to stream about
and the time just ticked by and I didn't
I didn't do it so today I had to come in
for meetings I got a haircut so like it
was I did things today that helped me to
feel better and so anyway I apologize
for not streaming I I could have found
time to stream but anyway hopefully I
get back on my workout routine and kind
of get back to normal with things
tomorrow I think I'm going to do a
stream but it's not going to be about
this project
tomorrow will be we're gonna work on so
Alex Castillo and I are gonna work on a
brain-computer interface with JavaScript
so we're still trying to get the headset
that I purchased working so we're
working on like that connection with how
to take get the data from Bluetooth and
get it into a format that we can use you
know Java scripts to do things with
basically so we'll see hope hopefully
that'll go well I haven't decided
whether I'll strain that on my channel
or on free code camps channel if you're
interested in that please subscribe to
my channel the links down below just so
you don't miss it I haven't really
talked to Quincy about whether or not
it's cool if I do that on free code
camps channel so we'll see I'm sure he'd
be ok with it
all right but enough talk let's get to
the code and I haven't taken my G fuel
yet so I accept GQ and coffee so I'm
gonna be switching off as always G fuel
I'm open to a sponsorship deal and I
mean you need to get on this there's 28
viewers you know G fuel you're missing
out and also
my Elle Fanning which is supposed to
help with brain function and stuff like
that so now that I've properly enhanced
my brain with these things let's get
started yeah Nikki the beard is gone
yeah I do want to say what's up to
everybody in the chat I see a lot of you
are saying hello
no boom seven says I can see why your
wife snagged you though
I always appreciate your comments that
they're always very entertaining one
question I do want to address so
Siberian says do I have to watch the
other projects to be able to follow
along with this one no you do not so the
projects are but you don't have to watch
one project or the other so I try to do
a good job of starting from scratch each
time and yeah and actually the first
projects may not be the best to watch
anyway because they'll be some of the
stuff's outdated you know they've come
out with new versions of the things that
we used so I don't want to say they're
entirely useless because we do cover a
lot of things that are pretty standard
and don't change but if you had to pick
to watch something I'd say watch the
newer whatever the latest project we're
working on it probably the best to be
able to get you know the information
that you could use immediately to help
you in your projects
Ryan says add row' I don't have a dural
I've never tried at a row I've heard
things about it but I've never so okay I
did want to show you all that I made a
playlist for this project and I know a
lot of you have been requesting this for
a long time
and I haven't done it is just pure
procrastination I could have made time
to do it just wasn't a priority for me
so I finally did it
so now you can see all of project 5
videos and I put it so that project the
day one shows up first and it goes in
order like that I think this will help
for new people who want to watch them in
order so for those who have already seen
them and want to see the latest one
it'll be a little odd because you have
to scroll down but the latest one comes
up like on the front page of free code
camp anyway so it should be too hard to
see that so anyway this is now on the
playlist I'm still gonna keep that long
playlist that has all the live coding
with Jessie stuff in there just people
are probably used to that I'm sure some
people you know have saved that playlist
so anyway I have it set up that it so
that it should automatically add the
videos to this playlist every time I do
a new video so but we won't forget
anything everything should be there so
I'm gonna see after I do this video if
this stream that we're doing now
automatically goes there not hopefully
it does but that's one project I think I
have a playlist for project four and I
want to get the other project soon so
everything will have a separate playlist
and we already have this is will be
video 51 for this project this is insane
a lot of videos
Nikki sy no YouTube dark theme for for
this YouTube thing I'm on the free code
camp account and I keep it with the
light theme I don't remember why I
didn't there was some reason why I kept
it with the light today maybe so I just
tell it apart because and so this is in
chrome and Chrome Canary I'm logged into
my own YouTube account and that is on
the dark
so it does help me because I don't want
to accidentally like reply to comments
as free code camp and stuff like that so
helps me keep it straight but I'm gonna
close that since we don't need that
anymore and see let's go
brian says add row' helps him a lot I
now let me know if I'm wrong on this but
you normally can't get a duro unless
it's prescribed for something correct I
can't legally like I can't just get out
at all to say like hey I want to you
know stay up and do a lot of coding
right I my pharmacist wouldn't be cool
with that it's unit testing that's right
oh you know what before we do that let
me make sure I start up and grow up and
give you all the link so we won't
necessarily be doing that much with it
in terms of like any front-end stuff
actually changing but you could maybe
see some of the changes that I've done
on the site and you know mess around
with a site on your own someone that's
why are we talking about
adderall uh-huh
it just got brought up so anyway yeah so
I don't brian says you have to have a TD
or ADHD I don't have either one of those
so I guess adderall is not for me
I'm really sorry I'm having trouble with
this name but presume is law I'm sorry
let me know how that's pronounced
because I'd really like to get it right
but anyway they asked have you ever used
docker for your projects I tried using
docker oh maybe at least a year ago
maybe maybe almost two years ago and I
started to work with it and then I had
some projects come up that were like
tight deadlines and so I I just kind of
set it aside because I wasn't good
enough with it yet that I could do this
project and I never picked it back up
I'd really like to learn more about
docker and use it but at this point my
doctor skills are not good enough for me
to you know work with on a you know real
project ok so let me give a very quick
summary of what I did what I've done in
the last few days you can always go to
the github repo links in the description
and check out the last few commits to
see what I've done inside the matrix as
your vs code as an update autumn
alright cool I'm not gonna run the
update right now just you know for time
reasons I mean usually they're really
fast but I just I just kind of want to
get started but thank you for letting me
know I will run that update maybe later
okay so I've added this Travis fought
what was a gamble that's how you say
ready for YAML files the mo file anyway
I've added this in here if you're not
familiar with Travis look up Travis CI
it's for continuous integration
basically it links in with sorry it
leaks I got distracted reading the live
chat it links in with github so that
every time we push code to github it
runs
before that that commit actually like
goes through so it's kind of another
layer of checking right because you know
potentially it wants I'm really the only
one committing so it's maybe a little
bit of overkill right now but I wanted
to have that that extra layer as a
safeguard but then also because we did
that we were able to we have Travis
we're able to hook up what was it green
keeper so green keeper is a it's a green
keeper bought something like that green
keeper will look at our package JSON
file and anytime there's an update to
one of the packages we have in there it
will either auto update by automatically
submitting a pull request with the
update or if if it's really out of date
and in Mike hello just like breaking
changes then it may just kind of alert
but that way we don't have to keep up
with all the updates ourselves will
automatically get pull requests with
those updates so I had to use Travis to
be able to do that I mean it probably
didn't have to be just Travis I'm sure
other systems like Travis little works
but we had used I'm using Travis on a
side project so Harshit who's in the
live chat frequently but it's too late
in this time zone to watch right now and
he's done a lot of work on these other
project he set it up in the side project
so I just kind of took what he did and
tried to adapt it so basically I have
the unit test running but I don't have
the end-to-end test running so I ran
into some issues with the end-to-end
test mainly due to trying to run a
headless browser with Travis and I
decided that it's not really important
right now and I needed to just move on
and get some stuff done so we're gonna
go back to it and at some point but for
right now I thought you know what we
don't
they have test coverage on all of our
components like not even close so if
we're gonna have this setup let's write
some unit tests also how to request from
somebody on Twitter about doing unit
tests so said all right let's do it
so that's what we'll be doing today and
what else that out I'm sure I worked on
some other things that I'm forgetting I
I know I did a lot of work on the the
router adding new routes making sure
links work so there's a lot more pages
that work now cleaned up a ton of data
on the WordPress side of things just
kind of combining things that were all
separate that didn't need to be
separated making sure the slugs were
were correct so doing a lot of that kind
of work which is not really fun it's
just really kind of time-consuming it
needs to be done so I don't really like
to stream that that kind of stuff okay
so let me let's first just check out
some of the tests that we have right now
so I'm gonna get rid of some of this
stuff we are going to use enzyme and
jest
so as far as as I know from what I've
looked up the last few days on unit
testing okay we have a question about
explaining what unit testing is I'll do
that right now let me start my timer
there we are so 25 minutes of code then
I'll go back to the live chat and answer
questions so a unit test especially in
the context of react would be like
you're testing one component all right
or you won if it wasn't react you could
test like one function right so it
you're not having this entire page and
then you know rendering the whole page
and seeing how it works
you're just saying like okay like I'm
gonna if I give this component these
props this should happen and the test
just checks to make sure the
that actually happens so for each thing
that you had each component each piece
of a component you want to write a test
ideally the way you're supposed to do it
you write the test first and the test
fails and then you make the test you
write you change your code so that it
passes the test so you think about what
are all the things I want this code to
do you put it all into the test and then
you know your code is good once it
passes all the tests and you make sure
you have test coverage because you you
test you grid birth to test first
now we've already done a lot of code
without testing so we're gonna have to
go back and write the tests usually when
you do it like that your tests aren't as
good but that's where we're at so maybe
moving forward we'll start doing tests
first you know at first when we started
this project I was on a much tighter
timeline and then things changed and now
I have more time so now we can work on
testing so let's see what tests we have
first since I have having index page
open here so let me let me make some
space and open this page yeah that's not
what I wanted to index all right so
here's the test that we have for the
index page and now this is not a
complete test this is just the start of
of the test that we have so oh I didn't
explain what just an enzyme is so just
is a testing I don't we call a framework
a testing tool I believe Facebook
created just that's what if I remember
correctly I think they did enzyme is
created by a different different people
created it so not Facebook but it is
recommended by Facebook for testing
react so
enzyme can enzyme makes testing a bit
easier and it can work with different
things so you don't have to use it with
jest you can use it for different things
alright cool Aniki says enzyme is airbnb
awesome Thank You Nikki that is that is
correct I do remember saying that I was
on their their github repo yesterday all
right so you can use enzyme with a lot
of different testing frameworks so we're
gonna use it with Jess today but it's
not just just so I I really am not
familiar enough with it to tell you all
the details about why you want to use
enzyme I read and watch videos about it
yesterday but I didn't retain everything
so I'll just take you through this basic
one first so we describe right so we're
saying index so the component index
which is this whole component right so
index should render right it should
render all right we have our little
arrow functions here if you're not
familiar with arrow functions like it's
just pretty much like a regular function
for for our purposes right now it's it's
pretty much like a regular function so
if you see this weird error thing just
think somebody's putting function making
a new function so it should render this
cost repair render index expect wrapper
I didn't write this that's I'm just
trying to figure out going on what's
going on so what does this mean are we
just rendering it renders a component
called index are they really that basic
so I guess we're just testing whether or
not it renders period like does this
component render at all so I mean this
is the most basic of test we need more
than than this
so we're gonna try to pick some piece of
this and add it now we have pieces like
this like here oh that's its own
component like we can write a separate
test for that component so what I'm
talking about a piece I don't mean a
separate component I mean you know
something within here that's not within
its own component which it looks like
everything else is in its own component
okay um do we have any special stuff
going on no we don't do it Wow all right
so we do need to make sure I guess that
some things are rendering right
Neela says how about using shallow
instead of pure render yeah you know
what I was wondering the same thing if
we can just use shallow render I don't
see why we need to use regular render
here everything that I saw it was saying
to use the shallow render so let's try
that out shallow hmm okay
so render do we have to replace this
with shallow
okay Nikki says then expected with to
match snapshot yeah
okay all right so we've got a lot of
chat about all the differences now in
the live chat so I mean I may wait and
hold off and go over that after our 25
minutes here which it may not be a bad
idea to bring up the basic documentation
for this as well so let me get that I'm
gonna get that ready on my other screen
and then if I think it'll be useful I'll
pull it over and share it with you
always whoa oh my I have a bunch of
windows open with just an enzyme
resources on my laptop I'm currently on
my my iMac so I don't have any of the
same stuff okay now's a great time to
mention that this is me doing my regular
work and it's a totally don't prepare
things ahead of time because I want you
all to see my mistakes too so that also
means that I frequently don't have the
the links ready all right so I do have
something useful so this is cool right
away it says shallow rendering renders
only the component itself without its
children so if you change something in a
child component it won't change the
shallow output of your component or a
bug introduced to a child component
won't break your components test it also
doesn't require the Dom okay so that's
the difference which is actually pretty
good I think that I like that right
because if there's an error in a child
component but it doesn't nestled all the
components I'd rather just have that
child component fail the test and not
the main component anyway so that makes
a lot of sense
I like this for sure let's see is the
difference okay
icon component okay cool so it doesn't
actually render out the components this
is awesome so this is what I kind of
like the basic test that we can do or
let's look at all the components that
are supposed to be on the index page and
let's make sure that they're actually
there alright so here's some snapshot
testing
oh cool here's some cool stuff why Jess
why enzyme let me just paste this link
in because I'm not gonna read through a
page on the stream but I will put the
link in there so that'll answer a lot of
the questions that I just saw on the
live chat about why would we use just an
enzyme Oh
even has you know how do you set it up
now we already have it set up in the
project so I'm not going to go over that
and I someone else set that up so I'm
I'm definitely not the one to tell you
how to set it up there we are so now
let's just write some basic tests and so
this for most non interactive components
our index page realistically is is
pretty non interactive we don't have
anything going on that responds to user
input at least not yet oops
yet nikola says the links of 404 try
copy manually copying and pasting the
link there's there's something weird
that happens with links in the YouTube
chat okay
it's night remember too much snow shot
just
all right I think I'm gonna move this
over to the other screen so I can go
back to the code and still see this so
at least on this page on our index page
I don't think we'll need to test events
but at some point we're gonna want to
test events like on click and things
like that
so let's see let's see if we should
change the way we're doing this and I
just want to make sure my syntax is
correct
also and make sure these aren't out of
date where I'm getting the syntax room
okay so we're describing index okay now
okay you know what I didn't need to
change renderer so the things that are
inside these are just what should happen
index should render and so we want to
shell a render check for index and we've
named it this Const wrapper and we're
expecting wrapper okay so now let's do
another test I believe we can do
multiple tests
right whoops let me make sure I don't
lose track of it should show Nicki says
it should shallow yeah that's good yeah
sorry about that
I just did my you know control I did
like my multiple cursors here and did
them both at once and not exactly what I
needed to do
okay mmm we're gonna do snapshots I
guess I guess the first thing we should
do is just see like have our changes so
far mess up anything right since I'm
learning this along with you all let's
go incrementally and we can just run
tests that's I forget what the command
is for for just running the unit test I
think it's just unit actually yeah let's
just try that let's go yeah unit test
hey cool
all right so the test did pass so we
haven't messed up anything too badly
which is awesome
all right cool Nikki thank you for
putting that in there that's what I was
just reading that on my other screen and
wondering like should we do that so
we're not going to just expect wrapper
you want to expect it to match snapshot
okay
so you want to do that and then yeah I
believe that we can just go down through
here and make sure I don't have to
confirm any of the terminal
okay let's do that yeah that's so we
should get a snapshot yeah we get a
snapshot file now so you can see now we
have the snapshot you sent your snap of
yeah I won't help with snap follow
snapshot tools
anybody use this let's try it I want
pretty colors on my snapshot do we need
to reload all right Rilla remove w from
wrapper or make the other one capital
all right let's see your snapshot is
okay now we have pretty colors Wow that
creates quite a bit Wow alright then
okay so
Aniki says all you're getting all that
extra JSON you snapshots yes yes it
looks like we can add something else in
that might help with that
I mean I guess it I guess this should
work for now so I'm not going to add
anything if this is working for now but
Nikki I guess
yeah we can make this Nikki you say we
should make this a lowercase W I'm cool
with that
all right so let's let's add some stuff
in here just to see if we can do it and
if it breaks then we know we can't do it
so I want to add another test in here
and we want to describe let's see
hero hero and let's see
chorus signing snapshot doesn't exist
yeah
sorry I'm trying to scroll down and see
how they did this they don't really have
examples and what I'm looking at now of
doing multiple tests all at once and it
looks like yeah isn't that terrible when
your tutorials all are doing different
things
really quickly
okay all right cool actually we also
have some other stuff here so let me
grab this so this another cheat or I get
is recommending that we test if it's
even defined that makes sense
expect index to be defined wonderful so
here's how we can do multiple tests on
index we can also we can check other
stuff with it but I think we're we're
gonna be okay
further right now
all right so I want to see if this will
work this guy feverish
actually no I don't think that'll be it
I think it would be up here describe
index it should
to render the new back to her I want to
go back to the snapshot I want to see
how this looks in the snapshot I know we
had a bunch of info but there's got to
be somewhere where actually we can see
it maybe
[Music]
okay Nikki's looking the up the thing
that that removes a bunch of the JSON
that's cool so this is pulling in a lot
of other stuff where's my actual
Oh
how about
what about this Nikki does this look
familiar
okay
all right cool let's see I don't even
know if I have this package no this is
gonna work
I'm not sure what was actually all right
cool yay we finally got a broken thing
cool
alright let's just get it then
let me know what you all think about
streams like this where I don't really
know what I'm doing either and we work
through it together I I mean I kind of
think there's some value in showing the
process of me like as a developer
working through something new but if you
think this is just kind of more of a
waste of your time because we're I don't
I mean we're just kind of working
through it then you know let me know
I'll try to only stream about things
that I'm more comfortable doing and have
more experience with or if you think
there's some value in this you know I'll
try to do this you know occasionally as
well all right so let's see if this
works
whoa
still not not working
yeah so you had a bunch of stuff
this gigantic file in here oh that's why
it's all this stuff from the theme
provider
Halla John says what you gonna tab up
with 5% battery left well just
preemptively since your tablet's gonna
die see you thanks for what
alright let's what did it say
interesting okay cool
so let's see what we get now after we
did that yarn unit you to update our
stuff alright we're still getting a ton
of stuff because that's coming in with a
theme provider component and then at the
bottom we have losses with styles index
page okay alright then
all right I am at the end of my Pomodoro
session so let's go five minutes I'm
going to come back to the chat and
answer as many questions as I can
well how there's a lot in the chat
already a boy says I'm excited about
this awesome
oh well so so far I don't know how how
good I've been doing but hopefully
you're still excited
I'm just scrolling through trying to
find things I haven't already answered
Oh world says testing always look like a
waste of time for me I don't know I mean
honestly it it seems like it would just
take a lot longer I'm trying to trust
and believe everything that I've read
and heard about testing that in the long
run it saves you time because there'll
be less to fix so that's that's what I'm
going with
one day of s if I use Pomodoro on a
daily basis I do I use Pomodoro
whenever I'm coding and just to break
things up and to help me estimate how
long things will take like I keep track
of how many Pomodoro sessions certain
activities take and then I can go back
and look through that and get a better
estimate of how long the future projects
will take excuse me sorry for the on ice
to drink more coffee
Kampai asks what's your vs code /
linting setup like Aniki says es linen
and prettier yeah yeah I mean that's
that's pretty much it I I have a lot of
other stuff with BS code I should do a
video on that because I do get that
question occasionally
Nilesh says what does enzyme to json
actually do okay and that nikki says
check out the snapshot after you run the
test to see the difference so it might
have been hard to catch with all that
extra stuff in there but hopefully you
could see at the bottom at least that
now we have like it looks like JSX right
before we had I don't know what did it
was it objects or I mean we had some
JavaScript stuff going on in there
before but it definitely wasn't JSX this
is a lot easier to read I mean
unfortunately we still have all this
stuff but now we can hopefully on some
other components we won't have all that
stuff and it'll be way more obvious what
what we see in the test Carlos says I
love it actually it's better cuz we
learn as you learn we see even your
train of thought on the process okay
cool so that was in response to my
question about like do you all like
whenever I come into a stream not really
knowing what's what's going on and we
learn as we go
brian says I like it because it makes me
feel better about myself when I struggle
I never get to see someone actually
figuring something out it's always
smooth sailing in videos all right cool
yeah I mean that was one of the things
when I originally started streaming that
I thought too is like hey there are a
lot of other people doing really good
videos and it is smooth sailing all the
time like why don't I do videos where I
do make mistakes and I do try to learn
it would be cool for people to see that
Raul says can I become a like you
someday trying to convince my parents
but all they need is to get me a
although ones get you a degree
Raoh I would say the best thing you can
do right now to try to convince your
parents is just get as good as you can
at being a developer and if you could
take on
projects I don't know how old you are
but if you can or what what the laws are
like where you're from but you know in
the United States you know you just
start taking on side projects and
working you know as a teenager so that
might be one way to prove that this is
realistic you know career-wise but if
your parents want you to get a degree
and you can get a scholarship or your
parents will pay for it I definitely
think you should still try for the
degree like keep working keep working
and getting better with coding but you
really can't pass up the opportunity for
a free or really discounted degree now
if you're looking at having to pay for
the whole degree yourself then it's not
such a good deal then I mean it kind of
depends on you know your country in the
situation you're in but if I had to
choose all over again and I had to pay
for the school myself I was lucky in at
scholarships I might just choose to
become a developer and work full-time as
a developer without the degree I
couldn't have got this job but I
certainly still could have got all my
freelance clients that I had before I
got this job so anyway but that does is
general advice so I don't know all your
particular circumstances so you know you
have to take that into into account all
right so my timer went off but I only
have a few more things in the chat so
let me just get these last few things
before we start up again let's see Aniki
says for that plug-in to work you need
add a Jess config JSON file okay cool
good to know
Patrick hey that's my uncle hey uncle
Pat how's it going I'm glad that you
could watch Patrick says in the comments
and the chat are great awesome
Nikki says all hearts should probably
set up the chest config inside your
package JSON yes I do believe
okay so role is saying I'm from India
and let me know if I'm pronouncing your
name correctly as well I don't have any
resources but very interested in coding
all right well I don't know exactly how
it is in India but in the United States
University costs
a lot of money for for most schools some
schools are more affordable but it does
cost a lot of money so it's it's it's
almost at the point right now for
universities that if you can't get some
type of financial help it's gonna take
you a really really long time to pay
back the loans that you have to take out
so if you want to go into a tech related
field where you don't really need a
degree to get a job it doesn't make
sense to spend all that money some so if
that's really true really want to do I
would say again try to get as good as
you can and get actual paying jobs to
prove to your parents that you can
really make money doing this that might
be the best way best way to go about it
my wife's calling me let me tell her I'm
doing a live stream hello hey I'm doing
a live stream you're on YouTube is it is
an emergency okay you want me a call you
want to know with the stream all right
hi okay
cool
oh my Uncle Pat's at the Denver Airport
watching that's cool that the Wi-Fi at
the airport is good enough to to watch
all right so I'm getting a lot more
questions now so I'm going to hold hold
off on these questions until after this
next Pomodoro cycle so let's get started
again I am gonna check quickly because
Nikki's putting some some stuff in the
chat about how to set this up all right
we need to also add a polyfill to the
setup files okay well let's let's go to
our package.json where's it that I
thought we opened it up and now it's not
here we mean I I need to close some of
this out it's way too much wow I didn't
realize I had so much open oh and there
it is there's my package Jason I thought
I had it open okay so let's see yeah so
here's our just sort of shims arches
okay we do have that polyfill already
there so yes I guess Harshit must have
already set all that up even has the
adapter for reacts 16 which is awesome
okay cool so maybe were we're all good
to go then
all right so let's um let's see I want
to try I got I really want to try to
make do a component that does something
more than the index should we do the
hero or sex section let's just do this
tech section because we don't we don't
have anything for that yet
so this will be like fresh test and
we'll try it out so let me just import
now I want to use what we what we just
did index test so let me copy and paste
this into a new file and what we're
naming these so this will be text
okay yeah so it's not pages index this
is going to be components slash text
text section
okay so in these ones we can at least
have section alright whoops
I forgot this part okay so so far we
haven't done anything different
we're just bringing in what we already
had and we just changed it to be tech
section instead of index but now we can
test well let's let's save it and just
verify that we haven't mess anything up
so far and then we can start to test
things like it does it if we pass it
this prop does it actually display that
right or you know any of these props so
we can go through each prop give it some
data some test data and then make sure
that it actually does what we want it to
do with that test data does that make
sense
so I just got distracted by a long email
chain that my boss is CC'ing me on okay
I'll just let them know I'll make the
update
okay so there's an update on a site that
didn't get made that's kind of important
that evidently someone else was supposed
to make so I'm just going to do it
before I leave because honestly it
doesn't really matter whose was supposed
to do it it needs to be done and I can
probably do it faster than anybody else
at this point
that's not bragging it's just like I
built the site so I can update it faster
okay so did I run this test I didn't
that was what I was gonna do let's run
the test cool all right so you can see
now we should have the text section
let's see what we get all right so
here's what it rendered out so text
section and let's see object here was
exception unit continues exercise very
button interesting actually you know
what we probably should check the
component as well that would be useful
so let's open up that text section
component text section there we are okay
so we can see here's what it what it has
all right so
interesting I had assumed that these
were some of the things that were
rendered like some of the components
inside child components but the tax
section section one interesting okay I'm
not exactly sure what all this is maybe
when we start adding some more tests and
changing things we will find out I'll
double check to see if any of you let me
know what okay all right so let's write
another test within that within that
file so let's just take so we have it it
should render I don't wanna this one
doesn't have any events so we're not
gonna test events for this one we may
not get two events today we might have
to do we might do another stream about
testing that'll be a little bit more
informative because well more practice
with it but we should I'm trying to find
the trying to find an example of how to
add crops
oh okay I remember now all right let's
let's go alright so it should render
check render text and let's say so we're
gonna do the text section and let's say
we're our props just go back to index so
I can see the props so let's say text
equals and then we could just give it
some text right maybe
why am I getting this once all multiple
spaces okay
let's see
I'm not sure if this is all I need but
let's see yeah let's see what happens so
save it and then let's run some tests
now we'll probably get that warning that
something changed did we know we didn't
ok cool maybe because it didn't change
maybe just cuz we added things there we
are
did it test section in class should
render text no actually that's not what
we wanted
I wanted it to actually render that
okay yeah I wanted it I wanted it to
show here like actual text inside of
this component I guess I'm doing it
wrong mm-hmm
you know let me go I'm looking up all
these tutorials but I should just look
up the documentation so if you want to
follow along I'm I'm going to the
official enzyme repository on github so
if you just type in enzyme github it
should be the first thing that comes up
in a Google search so I am going to
click on there there's a bunch of
options and one of them is using enzyme
la just I'm gonna open that in a new tab
for now and because the first thing in
the docs is basic you should usage
shallow rendering so I'm gonna look at
what what's going on there
just to make sure my my I guess syntax
is correct
so surrender texts so I notice that this
is the style they're using when should
render text wind past end which actually
is correct because it shouldn't render
and obviously it shouldn't render text
if no text is passed okay looks like
wrapper is just the default name that's
used throughout so that that makes sense
I was kind of wondering about that and
let's see
let's see
so you wanted to say okay tech section
text if we do have text it's not gonna
render right in the middle right it's
gonna render inside of a div class of
section test
she texts
okay so what will happen is it'll render
typography so all right let me see not
sure if this is the right way to do it
but let's try it out text section here
but then within this we're gonna write
typography
I don't know I don't have a good feeling
about this one pinkeye messing it up
mm yeah let me check this
yeah there's no way that's right let's
see
alright let's let me take this out for
now and start again
okay specs
okay I may have to go to the full
documentation
okay yeah Brian I think that's a good
idea I was just looking at that part of
the documentation let's try that out I'm
yeah let's just let's try it out and see
what happens I'm a little bit worried
about it because the text is gonna it's
gonna be within the typography component
so I'm not
yeah I'm not exactly sure how this will
render but I think that's it's worth a
try to see you know what's gonna happen
you know what shoot we we wanted to
match the snapshot we don't want it to
contain unique right that's that's what
we want maybe I ought to go to the one
that's specific for using jest with
ensign yeah that'll be more helpful
nice example tests
all right so I'm going to show I'm gonna
copy this into the live chat because
it'll be easier to just go right there
instead of me trying to describe how I
got there but this is the example test
with you if you're using jest with
enzyme so let's see see what they're
saying here
hmm
okay so we we can do different this is
good to know so we can do different
things within the same one so we don't
just have to do shallow or just just
render amount so that's good to know
okay
and I'm also going to check out the
shallow rendering API
[Music]
all right I just realized the example I
was looking at before when I was trying
to put a lot of stuff in here was not it
wasn't an example for passing props it
was for passing children so it made
sense for that but not not exactly for
props
hmm
all right I am NOT I'm not finding the
answers that I want for this
all right so there we go so I tried I'm
just gonna say this out loud somewhat
for myself but also for you uh-huh
just to know what's going on my head so
I the goal is to make sure that if we
pass in a prop it actually gets rendered
properly and so we tried to just put in
text section and pass in a prop like we
normally would expecting that it would
do something here but what we found is
that we just get back text section and
then down here it just has the prop we
don't actually see it rendered anywhere
this is kind of odd I guess some of the
things are odd to me we don't get
anything rendering inside here whereas I
expected that we would get the child
components you know not fully rendered
but that the child components would be
at least at least they would show up
so that's where I'm at you know
basically is what why is it not showing
up and what do I need to do to have that
show up and and test that
so let me show you alright so obviously
this is what we have right exports in
the text section right but here's what
I'm looking at as to you know maybe what
it should be so you can see here they
have exports so they have the component
as link but then under exports it has an
actual a tag with the href that they
passed in and the title here so you
could see like you know right here they
passed in title as a prop they passed in
monkey URL as a prop and we basically
have the same we have all this is the
same stuff right just not sure so I mean
maybe maybe I should compare maybe I
don't have all the same syntax here and
the same stuff maybe that's the problem
so maybe I shouldn't what if we don't it
looks like this is different
so describe text section
okay let's try that out now that I think
is the only difference that I noticed so
let's run this again let's see okay so
let's run that ad like we needed to
before there we are
okay now let's check what we have next
section same same thing right it's still
the same actually did we get no we
didn't get anything right
so we have now you know the first one
we're not actually doing anything with a
snapshot so this one and this one are
giving us snapshots and let's I just
want to be just double check that we are
getting one
hmm and this is what we're passing in
correct text yeah
interesting okay all right so my timer
went off again so that was our second
Pomodoro session I yeah I think I want
to end now I mean partly because I've
already put in over over time today so I
don't really need to be here anymore but
also I mean at this point I think the
best thing for me to do would be to do
some more research maybe a tutorial
because I'm I'm one number one a little
afraid that I'm mixing some little
techniques and some new techniques
because the tutorials that I have the
documentation I have right now some
glitch old and then yeah I kind of feel
like I've gotten to a place where I
don't have many more ideas left so I
need to get back to the research so
that'll be what I do between now and the
next time you come back to this which
will probably be after Easter
so I I said I'm probably gonna do a
stream from home tomorrow working with
that brain computer interface so it'll
be unrelated to this and then I'm off on
Monday and then so next Tuesday will
probably be the next time I stream so it
should be a while it'll give me a lot of
time to research I guess I mean
technically I'm off tomorrow too so I
don't really have three six so maybe
I'll research on Tuesday morning before
I stream okay so what I'd like to do now
is go back through the rest of the
comments and answer any questions that
you have you read out some relevant
comments okay Nicki says do a push yeah
thank you for reminding me yeah so if
any of you want to check out what was
done test things out you know mess
around feel free I'm about to push this
to the github repo the links in the
description everything in the repo is
completely you know open for you all to
use for whatever you want
I mean excluding obviously like the
Franciscan logo and stuff like that
can't use that all right I'm just
double-checking to make sure that the
things that changed or actually what we
expect to change and I will do a git add
to add everything and we're gonna do
yarn CM and that's a little tool we have
running on top of the normal get thing
just to help us make a nice commit
message otherwise you just want to type
in git commit and add the M flag and
then put your message so we're gonna add
we're gonna make this a test so this is
gonna say update and it should say add
tests for index dot J's and text section
J s okay no breaking changes I don't
think we have any issues for that so
it's going to run through hopefully it
can pass the test yep so passes the test
the cool thing about unit testing too is
it's very fast compared to end-to-end
testing because end-to-end testing
actually opens up ahead at least the way
we're doing it opens up a headless
browser and it has to wait for the Dom
to load the dawn in comparison to just
plain JavaScript is very slow so we
should probably write way more unit
tests than we do end-to-end tests if for
no other reason other reasons but one of
the reasons would be if we wrote a ton
of end-to-end test testing would take
forever but if we do unit tests you can
see look all four of our tests pass in
just over two seconds not really you
know not really that long to wait all
right so now I'm going to do a git push
and all of this code is now available on
github let me scroll up a bit try to
find where I left off and answer
questions if you have any questions
please put them in the live chat
and I just now realized that I have no
music playing in my headphones this
entire time I've been wearing them and
nothing's been in them and I feel silly
I guess I should turn music on that all
right now there's music all right Brian
says I'm looking into a startup that
will teach the computer science stuff
that actually matters plus coding it
would be about nine months to a year
kind of like College meets boot camp
interesting I've actually I had an idea
for something kind of like that here at
the university that I work for basically
you do it you wouldn't get a degree for
it but that would be good because we
could speed up the process of getting it
here and not have to worry about
accreditation and all the red tape that
comes with adding new programs but it
would basically just give you know a
certificate so it'd be somewhat like a
boot camp but we would have different
tracks so if you wanted to know an about
like web development you could do that
if you know we could offer some of the
newer exciting things so if you want to
about learn about machine learning you
could do that VRA are you could do that
and it would be something that the
computer science students could do like
let's say in the summertime to get
better skills it would be project-based
so they could put on their resume or
other people who aren't interested in a
degree could still come I'm kind of
thinking it would be online though so
they wouldn't necessarily have to come
here because then we have to figure out
all about like housing and stuff like
that so just to try to keep it like as
bare-bones as possible when it's easy to
start it would be online to start but
anyway I I've only talked to a few
people about it so far the people that I
have talked to hear about it I've said
it was a good idea I just need to get it
I need to be able to talk to people high
enough up that it can actually happen
but anyway so Brian I really like your
idea I I think that's a cool idea
because I have so people who do the boot
camps sometimes lack some knowledge that
a computer science students would have
gotten but it's it's not really it
doesn't really make financial sense for
boot camp people who have come out and
you know potentially have gotten jobs
already to go back and get a computer
science degree but if they could get
some of that in a boot camp format that
wouldn't that would make a lot more
sense I like that idea
Carlos says I honestly have no idea what
we are doing with these tests but I
think it's great to be doing testing I
used to do it with rails but you
definitely didn't get that much info on
the test whoo well hopefully Carlos I
don't know what I'm doing with these
tests either so we're in the same boat
just trying to learn learn as we go
along all right so here's some more
advice so Raul was talking about you
know advice - I'm sorry not Raul this is
a different question Kemah asked do you
have any advice for novice freelancers
so Pat says there are a lot of free
courses and training sessions on web
build as many webpage as possible that
training is valuable yeah definitely
that's how I am doing what I'm doing I
would say at least 90% of what I did
training wise was all free resources
yaqoob says how to pass variable from
routes to handlebars anyone I need to
display a number of documents in my new
MongoDB I haven't used handlebars in I
don't know like two years at least so I
I don't remember offhand I'm sorry if
anybody else is familiar with handle
using handlebars with MongoDB please you
know add add a comment in to help out
Jakub sorry I just I never use
handlebars that much and it
been a long time Rollo says currently
after my high school I'm taking a
preparation for entrance as last time I
was unable to qualify but this time I
hope for everything everything's go in a
good way
yeah well good luck with that I hope it
goes well for you too Bryan says does
anyone think the complete react guide on
udemy is any good or any books in
particular I haven't done the complete
react guide on udemy so I can't really
actually I've heard it pronounced you to
me have I been pronouncing it wrong the
whole time is it you to me or that makes
I guess that sounds better you tell me
you do me I don't know let me know how
you all pronounce it
udemy or you to me it doesn't really
matter you all know what I'm talking
about either way I guess yeah so I don't
I don't know because I don't have any
experience with that I do know that the
reacts nanodegree program with Udacity
was good I did go through that it was
good if you're already experienced
though with react and redux and maybe
have some experience with react native
it you might not learn as much from it
but if you don't have that much
experience with Redux and react native
then you could definitely learn a lot
from the course
oh okay so Carlos says that that's a
good one doing that one too okay cool
brian says I've read the road to learn
react Carlos says he explains everything
it's easy for him to understand okay so
I guess the the complete react guide is
is a good resource then rule says in
India every parent with their child to
get one of the government college and do
just a job and they don't understand the
in the internet at all this is as you
replied in my comments I'm very happy
well I'm glad you're happy about that
hopefully my advice is is good for you
like I said with me not understanding
the culture and you know the economics
and educational system in India I I feel
like I can't give you really good advice
really specific advice just kind of
general stuff from from my perspective
so just take that into consideration
when when you're thinking about you know
the advice that I gave you Carlos says I
had the idea maybe it's incorrect but I
thought that IT or anything computer was
taught in a lot of Indian schools I says
I've seen very good programmers from
India Pat says there is a lot of good
programming going on in Bangalore cool
yeah actually I just kind of as a side
note anecdotal most of most of my
viewers are from the United States but
in a close second I get a lot of viewers
from India as well so definitely a lot
of programmers or a lot of people
interested in programming watching from
India that Glen says hello from Spain
hey how's it going thanks for watching
hey Jones back
get a power cord
okay
aditya says am I the only new beer no no
way I'm a noob too so don't worry about
it and feel free to ask as many
questions as you want
Aditya says anyway what is he doing now
we're truck we were trying to figure out
how to do unit testing with some tools
called enzyme and jest so we we had we
made some progress and then kind of got
caught up when we were trying to test
out passing props in so if we do another
stream about this which we probably will
that's where we'll pick off or pick up
and then the next step would be testing
actions so like simulating user actions
and testing what happens so you know
what happens when you click on a button
and things like that
let's see and
brian says dude I'm a noob too so don't
feel like you're the only new we are
learning here yeah for sure we're all
Laurie everybody that's that's Cody no
matter how many years they've been at it
we're everybody still needs to learn
things are always changing there's
always more to learn Pat says once you
have a basic understanding of
object-oriented coding the rest is just
practical experience languages change
fast and new ones come out every year
yeah for sure that that's it I mean you
get the fundamentals down and the basics
then you can move from from different
languages and especially I know like in
react land you know we do more of like
functional programming but realistically
object-oriented is important to know
I've been doing some work with solidity
which is a language to build block chain
contracts on the etherion blockchain and
it's all object oriented the syntax is
very similar to JavaScript but I was
using a strongly typed version of
solidity called solidity X so it's it's
definitely like imagine like
object-oriented JavaScript like strongly
typed so that's kind of what it's like
but I started learning JavaScript before
like the whole functional programming
thing was really you know coming up so
when I started learning it was like
learn object-oriented you know stuff
with JavaScript style
I know Java scripts not really an
object-oriented language but people were
kind of using it like it was so that
experience helped me to be able to pick
up and learner solidity really quickly
and know what was going on so anyway so
I think there's still value in learning
object-oriented stuff it'll help you and
a lot of other things even though you
wouldn't necessarily need it for react
it still could help so it may not be
like I have to learn it right away you
could probably learn it on the side but
it's still still good
Carlos says new here also actually I'm a
clinical psychologist go figure so I
guess it's newer than a Newton cool
that's cool your clinical psychologist I
have my mother-in-law and my
brother-in-law are both in the field and
I have an uncle that's also in that that
field I guess yeah we're the counselors
yes oh and I think I have a cousin as
well I have a lot of people that I know
and then that field so very important
field let's see
Patrick says do you ever write
performance test I haven't yet but now
that you say that that sounds like a
really good idea maybe I'll have to I'll
have to look that up
and see how you know how to do that with
what I'm working with now krishna says
may i know the university name sure it's
Franciscan University of Steubenville so
I mean that's if you go to the github
repo for this project its links link
below you'll see the name of the
University it's used throughout you know
some of the places in the site so you
can get more info if you want it's a
small university in in Ohio in the
United States also says hey Jessie how's
it going not too bad
kind of struggled through this stream
but we got some stuff done learned a lot
okay so I've gotten to the end of the
live chat and I think I'm gonna finish
things up here and I'll probably see you
tomorrow hopefully things will work out
enough that we can get a decent stream
with with this brain-computer interface
stuff I'm very very new to it
Alex Castillo is going to be helping out
with that and he's much more experienced
he's a developer for Netflix but in his
spare time he works on brain computer
interfaces especially using JavaScript
with them so hopefully that'll go well
tomorrow and then we'll come back to
this project after the the Easter break
if I don't see you and you're
celebrating Easter this weekend have a
happy Easter and O'Brien says don't
forget to call your wife thank you cuz I
did forget thank you so much you just
saved me a lot of trouble thank you
thank you okay all right cool so all on
all CEO maybe tomorrow maybe next week
until then have a have a great day or a
great weekend a great holiday